die Freien Wähler im
Höhenflug Hubert eiwanger im
freudentumel ja liebe Freunde einer der
glücklichsten Tage meines Lebens
Rekordergebnis für die Partei
zweitstärkste Kraft in Bayern wir sind
damit Volkspartei in Bayern meine Damen
und
[Musik]
Herren CS mit einem historisch
schlechten Ergebnis neue
Machtverhältnisse in der Koalition
Bayern bleibt Bayern auch wenn die Welt
langsam verrückt wird aber wer sind die
Freien Wähler und wie rechts stehen
sie wir suchen Antworten am Stammtisch
in eiwangers
Heimatort bei politischen
Beobachtern und der
Wissenschaft 10 Tage vor der Wahl
unterwegs in Rottenburg an der laber
Niederbayern hier wird Hubert eiwanger
das erste Direktmandat für seine Partei
holen hier ist er als Sohn eines
Landwirts groß geworden und mit ihm die
Freien
[Musik]
Wähler zwischen Maisfeld und
gerstenacker treffen wir Anton Lorenzer
Landwirt Familienvater und Stadtrat für
die Freien
Wähler wenn ich da so schau was in der
großen Politik unsere Altparteien sag
ich mal so betreiben derzeit oder die
letzten Jahrzehnte eigentlich schon mit
dem haben wir einfach das war nicht die
selbst und drum die Freien Wähler was
ist es denn bei den Freien Wählern wo
sie sagen die sprechen mich an für mir
als Landwirt wo es die letzten Jahre
Landwirtschaftspolitik gemacht worden
ist das ist schon oftm oder macht für
uns Landwirte den W es relativ abgehoben
und nmer an der Basis und der Praxis ich
sage immer das ist so bisschen glaube
ich mittlerweile so bisschen scher
einfach zwischen Stadt und
Land Stadt oder Land ein näherboden für
Konflikte an dem sich die Freien Wähler
abarbeiten und entscheidend für Ihren
Erfolg sagt Politikwissenschaftlerin
Jasmin Riedel meinens haben wir in
Bayern eine der gesellschaftlichen
Konfliktlinien relativ stark ausgeprägt
nämlich die zwischen und Peripherie also
zwischen großstädtischen metropolraum
und dem ländlichen Raum was jetzt nicht
alles nur kleine Dörfer sein müssen und
diese
Konfliktlinie die bedienen die Freien
Wähler weil sie einfach so eine Partei
sind die sehr stark im kommunalen
verankert ist und deswegen können sie
genau auf dieser Konfliktlinie einfach
gut sich
präsentieren rel untersucht die Partei
und ihre Strategie analysiert mit einem
Team aus Informatikern und
Politikwissenschaftlern die Plattform Ex
ehemals Twitter in
Echtzeit was ja ganz interessant war bei
den Freien Wählern wenn wir uns mal
angucken wie stark die eigentlich auch
personalisiert sind ne also wenn wir uns
hier angucken der der Wahlkampf die
Freien Wähler setzen schon stark so auf
die auf Hubert allwanger ne als Person
oder also mehr vor allen Dingen sogar
noch als als die AFD
Hubert eiwanger das Gesicht der Freien
[Musik]
Wähler sein politischer Aufstieg ist
auch der Aufstieg der Freien Wähler
damals noch eine Partei ohne festes
politisches
Lager wir denken in Zielen und insofern
ist es für uns egal ob das Parteibuch
schwarz ist rot ist grün ist oder gelb
ist wir können mit denen allen
zusammenarbeiten wenn die Ziele ge 2008
beschert Hubert eiwanger den freien
wärland den Sprung in den Landtag lässt
die CSU auf das schlechteste Ergebnis
seit Jahrzehnten absacken
[Musik]
43%. jetzt in Nürnberg begrüße ich den
Bayerischen Staatsminister für Europa
und Bundesangelegenheiten Markus Söder
schönen guten Abend uns geht's ja im
Vergleich zu jedem anderen Bundesland
deutlich besser aber ein ist ist ganz
klar traditionelle Wählerschichten der
CSU haben sich diesmal versagt die
Freien Wähler die die hauptprofiteur
sind von dieser Entscheidung die sind
jetzt keine strukturierte Partei sie
haben profitiert von möglichen Fehlern
sie haben profitiert auch von dieser
Zurückhaltung der Wähler das ist wir
können sie zurückgewinnen denn wir haben
ja bei der Europawahl in einem halben
Jahr und dann bei der Bundestagswahl
genau die Aufgabe dies auch wieder zu
binden und dann auch wieder die Chance
auf die
50% die 50% wird die CSU nicht mehr
erreichen im Gegenteil 2018 schaffen es
die Freien Wähler erstmals in die
Landesregierung eiwanger wird
Wirtschaftsminister unter
Söder einer der die bayerische Politik
seit mehr als einem Jahrzehnt beobachtet
ist unser Kollege Alexander
Pool hast du damals gedacht dass die
beiden mal in der Koalition sind Söder
und
alwanger das sind ja eigentlich
Konkurrenten ne bis zum heutigen Tag
auch und eiwanger war immer klar dass
er er wollte immer näher an den Menschen
sein als die CSU die CSU hat diesen
Slogan näher bei den Menschen der
eiwangers Ziel war es immer zu zeigen
ich bin noch näher dran als ihr wann
immer es irgendein Bürgerbegehren gab
gegen eine Umgehungsstraße gegen ein
Gewerbegebiet ist eiwanger hingefahren
und hat sich dann mit diesem
Bürgerbegehren solidarisiert und hat
sich davorhin hingestellt wir treten wir
die freien weder ich Hubert anger trete
ein für die Interessen der Menschen nahe
dran an den Menschen einer von
ihnen zurück in seinem Heimatort
Rottenburg an der laber alle paar Wochen
kommen die örtlichen Freien Wähler im
Gasthaus zur Vorstandssitzung zusammen
wir wollen später noch von Ihnen wissen
wie rechts sind die Freien Wähler wer
sind denn die freien wer überhaupt doch
sitzen und und wie wie sind die freien
sch
mir absolutes gutes Team seh
vielfältigckerf offen
ehrlich wir sprechen den ganzen Abend
lang Fragen in die Runde was bewegt sie
dazu für die Freien Wähler Politik zu
machen mein Vater war schon bei der
Freien Wähler und der war jahgang 15 und
ich habe als Kind schon immer
mitgekriegt dass total Spaß gemacht hat
hab 2000
mitfangen und Z warar war wir junges
Team und hat wirklich Spaß gemacht und
es macht weiterhin viel Spaß wie war
denn derert eanger als er gerade so in
die Politik
eingestiegen also ich finde es ist ein
super Kumpel und ist super Politiker
worden also
m so vorstellen ich habe politischfangen
ich bin nicht in stat alleine wir in
Stad dre kmer Hubert allwanger sei nicht
die Partei aber einer von ihnen sagen
Sie Hubert eiwanger sorgt dafür dass die
Freien Wähler in Bayern der Art hohe
Zustimmungswerte haben ja aber die
Freien Wähler gibt es auch ohne Hubert
eiwanger ich glaube auch ehrlich gesagt
dass es viele bei den Freien Wählern
geben wird also Mitglieder die
vielleicht die Füße stillhalten aber
denen diese außerordentliche Prominenz
und diese Richtung in die die Freien
Wähler in ihrem Image gehen wegen Hubert
eiwanger gar nicht so seh
[Applaus]
schmeckt da ist zum einen die
flugblatffäre die an eiwanger klebt die
Vorwürfe antisemitische Hetze
hitlergrüße in der Jugend eiwanger
entschuldigt sich und geht einen Tag
später zum Angriff
über wurde von langer Hand geplant den
fertig die umfragete steigen und dann
ist da noch
Ering Menschen demonstrieren hier im
Sommer gegen das sogenannte
heizungsgesetz der Ampel und
mehr jetzt ist der Punkt erreicht wo
endlich die schweigende große Mehrheit
dieses Landes sich die Demokratie wieder
zurückholen muss und denen in Berlin
sagen ihr habt wohl den Arsch offen da
oben meine Damen und Herren
Erding du hast darüber
berichtet wie hast du das wahrgenommen
was ging dir da durch den Kopf also als
ich das gesehen habe auch diese Rede ist
mir wirklich kalten Rücken
runtergelaufen weil das so das klarste
Zeichen dafür war dass er mit den
Ängsten und mit mit der Verunsicherung
der Menschen spielt das sind Dinge die
einen so ein bisschen an die Weimarer
Zeit erinnern was macht eiwanger da mit
seiner Partei wo will er hin würden Sie
Hubert eiwanger als Populisten
bezeichnen ja
ist schon Populist ich glaube es ist
halt an der Stelle wichtig sich klar
zumachen was bedeutet Populist also was
heißt populistisch zu sein ja Populist
ist jemand der diese Klaviatur spielt
von wir hier unten gegen die da oben wir
die wie auch immer geartete normale
Bevölkerung die einfach redet und
einfache Bedürfnisse hat gegen den Staat
gegen das Establishment und das macht
Hubert eiwanger sehr ordentlich eiwanger
der
bierzeltwahkämpfer eiwanger der wre
Wirtschaftsminister der einfache Mann
der gegen das Establishment poltert
manche ziehen Vergleiche zu Donald Trump
ihr eiwanger ein Populist find dass der
Begriff Populist nicht zu ihrm passt es
sei den es werde die Bürgernähe als
solches
ausgelegt aber aber genau das ist ja das
was was ausmacht diesen trampismus
dermer der Hubert danach gesagt wird
jetzt in den in den Medien sich die die
Opferrolle umkeh ja finde ich totaler
schm die freien W s nicht rechts die
freien wellle Sprechen vielleicht manche
Dinge aus die den den
Normalbürger auf den auf den auf den
Fingernägeln brennen und dann wird es
dann vielleicht manchmal hinein
interpretiert aufgrund dieser Aussage
muss er dann einfach recht sein weil es
so ist W uns frei als rechtsbetitel der
wei ich nicht kennt uns nicht nicht
wirklich mitm Programm oder mit die
Ansichten deri beschäftigt in die rechte
Ecke habe ich ehrlich gesagt null
Verständnis weil wir gesagt mir so
glaube ich so so liberal wie die Freier
well vielleicht FTP
man wie rechts sind die Freien Wähler
die Freien Wähler haben sich völlig klar
aus meiner Sicht als rechte Partei oder
als Partei rechts der CSU etabliert
mittlerweile neben der AF
es gibt ja
dieses Diktum von Franz Josef Strau dass
es neben der CSU keine demokratisch
legitimierte rechte Partei geben darf
die gibt's jetzt also es gibt die AFD
und es gibt die Freien Wähler die sich
ganz klar auf dieser Seite positionieren
und die stärker werden muss man auch
konstatieren links rechts Jasmin Riedel
hält diese Kategorien für
verkürzt sie unterscheidet viel mehr
zwischen progressiv und traditionellen
zwischen wirtschaftspolitisch linken und
wirtschaftsliberalen im Wahlkampf seien
die Freien Wähler konservativer
Hauptfeind die Grünen aber wie rechts
stehen die Freien Wähler wenn man nur
ihr Wahlprogramm analysiert rechts find
ich ist mal so ein bisschen schwieriges
Konstrukt ein schwieriger Begriff weil
auf welcher Achse denn jetzt rechts ja
also sie sind wirtschaftspolitisch
tendenziell rechts der Mitte also
Wirtschaftsliberaler und sie sind auch
auf der
gesellschaftspolitischen Achse so ein
bisschen traditioneller aber sie sind
jetzt nicht rechts im Sinne von
rechtspopulistisch oder rechtsradikal
was man mit dem Begriff manchmal auch
verbindet am Wahlabend treffen wir die
Freien Wähler aus Rottenburg
wieder die ersten Hochrechnungen sehen
die AFD vorne als zweitstärkste Kraft
Schock im
Saal der Auftritt der AFD der
plakatieren einfachen Lösungen
projizieren das kann die AFD das macht
die AFD und deshalb wird die AFD dann
eben vielleicht
gewählt später am Abend die AFD hat zwar
die größten Zugewinne aber zweitstärkste
Kraft sind die Freien
Wähler wie geht es denn mit den freien
wäern jetzt weiter ich denke dass der
Weg der freien Wäller noch lange nicht
am Ende ist wenn man auf Gesetze wenn
man auf auf
auf Themen Einfluss nehmen will dann
geht es nur über die Landes und über die
Bundespolitik V 30 Jahren vielleicht
belächelt wir dass das Ziel der freien
wellle ist in den Landtag einzuziehen
jetzt sind wir eine feste Größe im
Landtag und warum soll die Entwicklung
der Freien Wähler nicht so weitergehen
und
eiwanger so stark wie nie im
Landtag seine Ambitionen gehen aber über
die bayerischen Landesgrenzen
[Musik]
hinaus